[Musique]
oui verna par un autochtone ici ses 1100
morts lundi vu cette semaine vous pouvez
imaginer que si vous avez eu la même
je dirais le même fil de nouvelles que
ce soit sur les grands médias ou les
médias sociaux vous avez entendu parler
des oueds souhaité m encore une fois on
se croirait retourner au début de la
pandémie en débit de 2020 avant qu'on
ferme les frontières où les gens ont
découvert les ouates souhaité m la
différence aussi entre les formes de
leadership ce à dire leadership
rationnelle leadership du conseil de
banque et tous les mélanges qui existent
au fil des nations entre ces deux
formules parce que la formule
traditionnelle c'est la formule qui n'a
pas été altérée avec l'arrivée des
colonisateurs qui a souvent dû même se
cacher pour se protéger contre les lois
telles que la loi sur les indiens qui
cherchait à étendre ses formes de
leadership là et bien sûr le leadership
de des conseils de bande qui ont décrit
avec la loi sur les indiens et qui ont
une juridiction créée par la loi sur les
indiens donc le mélange qui existait
entre les droits ancestraux et les
droits liés à la la réserve ont beaucoup
servi au niveau de la discussion quand
on parlait des enjeux du web souhaitant
en 2020 on arrive en 2021 et on revient
dans les mêmes enjeux mais ça devient
encore plus corsée parce que
présentement on a vu l'arrestation
d'environ trente deux non seulement des
gardiens du territoire des alliés des
gardiens du territoire mais aussi des
photojournalistes et des personnes des
médias qui venait témoigner un peu comme
ce qui manquait pendant la crise d'oka
cette
vision est ce qu'on avait eue avec
alanis obomsawin a changé totalement la
vision du québec autour de la crise
d'oka et bien ces personnes là c'était
moins la neutre ou si on était à rsa
arrêté pendant la dernière semaine et
toute la mobilisation qui se fait
présentement en ligne pour non seulement
appuyé les watts ou et n sur leur
territoire traditionnel mais aussi toute
la mobilisation qui se fait pour aider à
leur frais jury parce qu'on s'entend que
c'est une pratique qui a été fait par le
passé d'enterrer les militants
protecteur du territoire qui sont dans
leur droit les droits qui sont reconnus
par la cour suprême et de les enterrer
sous du juridique pour que justement
l'enjeu s'éteignent par lui-même et
pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce que le
choix du moment où ces arrestations
cette imposition de l'injonction qui
avait émis est justement l'arrivée d'une
grc quasi paramilitaires militaires même
par la présence de gilets pare balles de
gros fusil sur le territoire où est
souhaité m n'est pas une coïncidence car
par le passé ont leurs vues dans
beaucoup de mobilisations dans l'ouest
canadien on utilise des moments fragiles
c'est à dire des fois quand il y à des
décès des enterrements parce que des
cérémonies justement finira qui sont en
place mais le présentement ça tombe
exactement au même moment où justement
le la province du bbc de la
colombie-britannique suffisamment aurait
eu besoin que ses ressources militaires
l'heure où policiers soient utilisés
pour tous les enjeux justement liée aux
inondations et aux glissements de
terrain à la coupure des autres et
pourquoi on a pris ce moment là c'est
que toute cette coupure de routes là est
parfaite pour justement permettre qu'il
n'y ait aucune solidarité aucune
mobilisation qui viennent des autres
régions qui veut se déplacer puisque
tout le monde est occupé présentement à
gérer justement ces situations-là liés
au changement climatique et donc maman
parfaite où les médias aussi on les
caméras de tourner vers les inondations
vers ce qui touche justement la
population la colombie britannique en
grand nombre pour pouvoir faire des
interventions qui il ya deux ans presque
deux ans avait mobilisé les gens dans
les médias dans l'opinion publique et
avait amené beaucoup du sport ou est
souhaité m l'enjeu étant le même de
vouloir garder les territoires de voir
les protéger car ce sont les ressources
pour 17 futures générations mais non
seulement ça c'est d'avoir aussi le
débat est nourrie
entre les chefs de bandes et les chefs
traditionnels les chefs devant disant
qu'il ne respecte pas ce qui est fait
présentement ils reprochent justement
militants de créer du débat alors que
les chefs traditionnels rappel ou chef
de bande que ce n'est pas leur
juridiction même s'ils sont consultés
constamment par les gouvernements pour
avoir l'approbation ce n'est pas leur
place de donner une juridiction sur un
territoire ancestral qui est issu de
droits ancestraux donc qui est sous la
juridiction des chefs ancestraux alors
de pouvoir voir le débat qui existe
entre les chefs traditionnels et les
chefs ancestrale garde occupé aussi dans
la discussion sert un petit peu de
pavillons pour provoquer on a
l'autorisation des chefs de bande
cependant c'est vrai que leur
juridiction de chefs de vente lie à ce
kit à la banque faut pas négliger non
plus à travers le canada fait toutes les
formes de leadership sont très
différentes certains chefs de bandes
sont aussi des chefs traditionnels donc
pour les deux chapeaux mais réagirait de
façon probablement différente dans ces
enjeux là mais à ce point ici les chefs
traditionnels sont très clairs sur
donjons friction disent on ne veut pas
de ce passage de costing à ce manque
donc un passage des gazoducs qui se fait
sur le territoire qui a toujours été
opposé par le passé encore une fois va
être débattue jusqu'en cour suprême
jusqu'à ce que le projet soit retenu
justement comme quelque chose qui n'est
pas valide n'a pas il n'y a pas de droit
d'être sur le territoire mais comme il a
été fait il va être compensés et ce
n'est pas la compensation que les
communautés veulent en grande majorité
ou que les gens qui sont sur ce
territoire avait la grande majorité mais
bien arrêter ce genre de projet l'heure
sur leur territoire d'ailleurs une des
farces qui est souvent utilisé c'est
pourquoi est ce que vous nous reprochez
de bloquer des chemins de fer si vous
les avez construit ou est-ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'avocat d'affaires à
exister donc c'est de vraiment faire
clairement reconnaître que ce sont des
droits qui ont des bas bruit constamment
même s'ils sont des droits que le
gouvernement et que la cour suprême du
canada et que la constitution même du
canada reconnaît sida c'est intéressant
mais cependant
il l'est moins c'est de voir justement
qu'encore une fois on
judiciarise des personnes autochtones
sur des droits qui sont reconnus et
qu'on les enterre sous des processus
qu'on l'ait
il faut pas oublier non plus quand
l'économie britannique la relation des
communautés autochtones avec la grc a
même été la sphère d'un rapport de human
rights watch sur les femmes assassinées
divers donc vous pouvez imaginer le lien
de confiance qui existe entre une police
qui vous arrête et qui a été par le
passé aussi responsable de
comportement problématique en voir une
partie de votre population ça peut être
assez effrayant donc il faut suivre ça
faut s'y intéresser et ce qui est assez
différent je dirais de la crise d'oka
des oueds souhaitait en 2020 vous êtes
soumettant une version 2021 probablement
2022 c'est la présence des médias deux
journalistes une meilleure compréhension
des enjeux donc la discussion est un peu
plus clair en 2010 on a passé beaucoup
de temps à expliquer les modèles de
leadership présentement on va encore
continuer à utiliser le code et watsu et
n comme qu'aux écoles mais il faut aussi
voir les tactiques qui sont utilisés par
le gouvernement c'est à dire d'utiliser
des moments fragiles pour les
communautés et qui par le passé n'était
jamais couvert par les médias
de militariser sa police de l'envoyer à
un
support des industries
justement qui sont problématiques pour
les communautés autochtones et tout ça
sous le contexte d'un engagement de la
réconciliation est juste après la coop
donc cet axe est extraordinairement
ironique mais un moment d'histoire qui
peut bénéficier beaucoup de l'appui du
public mais aussi d'un réveil collectif
par rapport aux droits et aux enjeux
d'accord alors nous invite à vous y
intéressez à suivre l'enjeu justement
dans les médias en demander plus
justement pas uniquement des
chroniqueuses mais des journalistes des
grands médias parce que plus on va en
parler plus cette réconciliation loeb a
accéléré et plus les enjeux complexes
des communautés autochtones vont devenir
des enjeux qu'il faut partir de la même
réalité que ceux des enjeux allochtone
dans l'esprit des canadiens alors
n'hésitez pas à partager ce vidéo
n'hésitez pas non plus à nous envoyer
des questions et oubliez pas que la
version de notre
vidéo se trouve aussi dans plusieurs
plateformes pour ce qui est des
baladodiffusions je vous souhaite une
bonne semaine